we shall miss these days emotions run
high during meetings of the Women's
Committee in botando Township fear in
the community is palpable botando is
located in Zambia's copper mining belt
the slag heaps from the mines begin
right on the edge of town dust and
poisonous fumes are making people sick
we mainly fear chest problems we also
have people bleeding from their noses
especially children many have irritated
eyes and some have a rash four years ago
the Zambian government sent a team of
doctors to report on the consequences of
mining for residents health their final
report was never made public the
residents of Bhutan doe feel abandoned
since 2012 we haven't heard a word from
the government about that report we want
that report that's the reason why we're
so angry nothing has happened since then
they must give us that report results
that wage war at what Peter think amber
is an environmental activist from Zambia
a few years ago he founded the aid
organization citizens for a better
environment
he and his organization support the
women of Bhutan doe citizenship in
environment handles issues of ecological
justice and these people have undergone
a lot of sufferings because of
environmental injustice the mining
operations here which have affected them
through the emissions especially the
acid mist emissions from the tailings
leach plant which the mining operation
here has to make sure the people are
being heard Petersen cambers
organization fights in court against the
mining companies the mining industry is
the backbone of the Zambian economy
mining companies are very powerful and
environmental concerns are extremely
difficult to address
this copper or heap in Bhutan dough is
sprayed every night with sulfuric acid
the wind carries the acid mist
throughout the entire village Petersen
can be used to be a successful
businessman now he uses his public
standing and his money to expose the
conditions in Zambia's mining belt
initially the mining company put up some
mitigation measures but they have not
wept so since now there's an issue of
the report was the people supposed to be
not located and it is very clear that
government is not keen to get them out
so we our next step is to go to court to
try and first come into his report the
residents say acid rain is eating holes
into the roofs of their houses and
nothing grows in the family gardens
anymore children suffer the most from
the severe environmental pollution
Elizabeth nika's was grandson is at the
doctor's office all the time the boy
couldn't breathe and had pain in his
chest and he started bleeding from his
nose and developed a rash we went to the
hospital and he got an asthma inhaler
his father has the same problem it
started three years ago
access to the industrial park is barred
for camera teams while driving by we see
tanker trucks on the roadside they are
loaded with sulfuric acid the copper ore
heaps like almost everything around
Bhutan dough belonged to the Swiss
mining company Multi Glencore this is
the smelter which is responsible for the
emissions affecting the people in terms
of their chest problems eye problems and
so on and so forth
back at Peterson Kambiz office the next
group of people is waiting for his help
he says his mission is not over by a
long shot
in 2013 he founded the Green Party of
Zambia by going into politics he now
plans to fight the consequences of
Zambia's environmental destruction at
the national level